[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le journal
de tv 78 nous sommes le mercredi 13
septembre les titres de cette édition
ce sera officiel ce soir sous grande
surprise paris devrait obtenir
l'organisation des jeux olympiques 2024
pour fêter cette attribution une soirée
spéciale se déroule en ce moment même au
vélodrome national de saint quentin en
yvelines
nous serons sur place dans quelques
instants lutter contre la disparition
des commerces de proximité c'est le but
de ma boutique à l'essai dispositif
initié par le parc naturel régional de
la haute vallée de chevreuse le premier
local du genre en ile de france vient
d'être inauguré à magny les hameaux
il s'agit d'un salon de coiffure et puis
c'est un rendez vous phare chaque année
les 16e rencontre de la cense se
tiennent de vendredi à dimanche trois
jours dédiés à l'éthologie on en parle
avec anne de sainte-marie et directrice
du haras de la cense et nous prenons
tout de suite la direction du vélodrome
national de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
retrouver notre envoyé spécial michel et
demi d'euros alors l'enceinte fait ce
soir les jo-2000 24 qui devrait être
normalement sauf retournement de
situation attribuée à paris et l'
annonce officielle michael est imminente
de l'annnonce du cio à lima
l'effervescence monte ici au vélodrome
de saint-quentin-en-yvelines comme vous
pouvez le voir juste derrière moi ils
sont de plus en plus nombreux à venir
ici se rassembler pour partager ce
moment historique et les sportifs sont
également impatient je suis avec quentin
la fin le pistard de l'équipe de france
quentin vous avez hâte d'avoir la
décision finale du cio
même si on sait plus ou moins que la
france devrait obtenir les jeux
olympiques
oui hâte hâte de découvrir finalement l'
annonce officielle on a suivi cette
candidature plus ou moins de prêts
finalement nous les athlètes équipe de
france et voilà on est ravi de l'issue
qui se précise et du fait que voilà on
risque d'accueillir les jeux
en 2024 à paris
saint-quentin-en-yvelines ça c'est
génial pour nous on a un velours homme
d'exception ici donc on a hâte
on a hâte de vivre de vivre ce moment
qu'est ce que ça représente les jeux
olympiques pour un sportif vous avez
participé d'allier jéhovah vous avez
participé à des grandes compétitions
qu'est ce que ça représente pour un jeu
pour les jeux olympiques par ce parti
alors les jeux pour un sport comme nous
un peu enfin une discipline comme nous
un peu amateur c'est la plus grande
compétition que à laquelle on puisse
participer
donc c'est voilà l'objectif d'une
carrière l'objectif de fin voilà de
chacun d'entre nous c'est un des plus
sûrs des plus grands événements sportifs
au monde donc donc clairement voit la c1
c'est un rêve pour tout un tas de jeunes
sportifs aussi c'est vraiment enfin
voilà qu une compétition que l'on entend
quand on fait du haut niveau on cherche
à vivre d'autant plus voilà si si ça se
passe en france c'est encore le
commandant l'effervescence est encore
plus importante et voilà l'excitation
est encore plus importante les 160
justement aujourd'hui dans cette journée
spéciale j'ai ici au vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines comment vous
avez vécu cette journée du coup en tant
que sportif du coup on a nous fait
découvrir un peu notre lieu
d'entraînement il ya eu beaucoup de
passage ici au vélodrome de saint
quentin
tout au long de la journée beaucoup de
jeunes qui sont venus découvrir la piste
et puis tout un tas de sport olympique
le badminton y avait du judo aussi au
milieu donc on était ravi de pouvoir
accueillir accueillir cette journée ici
au vélodrome et puis et puis voilà on
attend on attend la danse il ne reste
plus grégory que deux petites heures
avant l'annoncé officielle du cio à lima
merci michael et merci à quentin
lafargue vous restez sur place pour
vivre cette soirée nous y reviendrons
dans notre édition de demain
et la fête a démarré plus tôt dans
l'après-midi au vélodrome nationale avec
comme vous le voyez sur ces images de
patrick jacques de dixmude un grand
flash mob dans la fosse de l'enceinte
réalisés par les enfants
des écoles du territoire nombreuses
animations au programme séances de
dédicaces en présence de sportifs
tricolores ou encore démonstrations de
l'équipe de france de cyclisme sur piste
plus de 850 jeunes scolaires ont envahi
d'ailleurs licra saint quentinois pour
soutenir la candidature de paris aux
jo-2000 24 les athlètes en herbe ont pu
s'essayer à une vingtaine de sports
michael et demi d'euros les a suivis
[Applaudissements]
l'effervescence des jeux olympiques a
frappé le vélo troubles national de
saint quentin en yvelines ce mercredi 13
septembre à quelques heures de la liste
officielle du seiu sur l'attribution des
jo à paris en 2024
parmi les temps forts de cette journée
850 enfants sont venus de toute la
région pour participer à une quarantaine
d'ateliers sportifs
aujourd'hui c'est très très important
d'associer les enfants à cet événement
parce que les enfants mais c'est
l'avenir c'est l' aventure olympique qui
commence pendant l'ensemble de la
journée les enfants âgés de 7 à 13 ans
ont pu tester entre cinq et huit sports
différents
l'escrimeur on a déjà vu à la télé
et pas n'a jamais fait le golf mode ce
que j'ai fait c'est du mini golf c'est
bien parce que y'en a que j'ai jamais
fait je vais découvrir et meynac j'ai
déjà fait mais du coup bah ça va
permettre de m'améliorer
les enfants ont également pu rencontrer
une dizaine de champions français parmi
eux thomas levet ancien golfeur
professionnel
le sportif a animé des mini ateliers sur
le thème du golfe moi quand je commence
j'ai commencé le sport c'est en
rencontrant des champions parce que tout
d'un quotidien as j'ai rencontré un tel
qu'est ce qui fait qu'un soir tu
commences à te qui intéresse un petit
peu plus tu regardes les résultats et
puis tu dis à tes parents dit moi papa
j'aimerais bien faire du judo par
exemple j'aimerais bien faire du golf
mais les champions bas ça ça aide
toujours à passer le cap en se disant
tiens je vais le faire le sport j'essaie
j'aime bien et allons-y
thomas levet suscitera peut-être lui
aussi des vocations chez les jeunes
scolaires mais avant de penser à
remporter une médaille d'or aux jo-2004
travailler son swing
il n'y a pas que saint quentin en
yvelines qui est à la fête aujourd'hui
versailles aussi organiser des
animations pour les enfants une journée
olympique que vous découvrez sur ces
images de nicolas kirillovitch si les jo
de 2024 à paris sont bien confirmés ce
soir la ville yvelinoise accueillera les
épreuves de sports équestres et de 1,1
plomb moderne ainsi que de cyclisme sur
route
plus d'une centaine de jeune versaillais
étaient présents cet après midi nous
reparlons bien entendu des jo-2000 24
reportage réaction est invitée jeudi
dans le 7-8 journal et dans le 7-8 débat
avec vanessa meflah c'est une première
en 20 ans la consommation de viande a
baissé en france tendance qui s'explique
par la multiplication et des régime
végétalien ce mode de vie consiste à
bannir de son alimentation
les produits d'origine animale dans les
yvelines
le phénomène prend racine les
établissements n'hésitent plus à bannir
les hamburgers et les entrecôtes de leur
venue au profit des lentilles et des
salades
reportage de michael et demi d'euros
bonjour madame je cherchais donc ce que
je vous ai demandé par téléphone
c'est parfait c'est déjà tout près voilà
premier client de la journée pour
mathieu au musée dans son qu'à
rambouillet à 38 ans cet habitant de
bullion s'est lancé en juin dernier dans
le concept de la nourriture vegan des
recettes qui consiste à bannir les
produits d'origine animale pour réussir
son projet n'a pas hésité à investir
près de 10000 euros
c'est un business qui est en train de
l'être c'est une niche encore et voilà
donc c'est effectivement plus
intéressant
et plus rassurant aussi que de se dire
voilà je vais lancer un énième camion de
pizza
le restaurateur propose une carte qui
évoluent en fonction des saisons
aujourd'hui mathieu propose des wraps de
falafel des croquettes de pois chiches
là c'est 100% derrière n'y a absolument
aucune trace de deux produits d'origine
animale ne pas de l'ehpad of pas de
beurre une recette qui fonctionne ils
sont une vingtaine à venir chaque jour
devant son stand on n'hésite pas à en
parler autour de nous et c'est une
grande découverte pour certains j'ai des
amis qui ne sont pas mes gammes que
jamais été dernièrement et qui sont
vraiment apprécié du début jusqu'à la
fin
qui est allé chez les plats donc si
mathieu a pour projet d'ouvrir un jour
un restaurant vegan dans les yvelines
d'autres ont franchi le pas
c'est le cas de cet établissement
versailles et odette et tristan bons
voeux nous ont été les précurseurs de la
cuisine végétalienne dans les yvelines
en ouvrant dès septembre 2015 on est
vraiment très content quand on a ouvert
on a un savait pas exactement à quoi
s'attendre
parce que ce type de ce type d'offre
existait pas on y croyait parce que nous
même on consommait sur notre produit et
on a tout de suite
une autre notre clientèle à nous
et on a beaucoup d'habitués qui viennent
régulièrement de plus le développement
de la tendance végal les deux
trentenaires ont connu près de 20 % de
clients plus aujourd'hui ils servent 50
à 70 couverts par jour en semaine et
plus de 100 le week end la mode touche
même la gente masculine n'est pas parce
qu'ils sont et qu'ils n'avaient pas être
assez nourris ba aujourd'hui c'est font
plaisir et
et bien aujourd'hui on a des tables des
quatre pour répondre à cette hausse de
la demande ces deux versets vont même
déménagé de leurs 30 mètres carrés rue
de sa tournée pour un établissement deux
fois plus grand dans le même quartier
rendre la culture accessible à tous
volonté du nouveau magasin cultura il a
ouvert ses portes aujourd'hui au centre
commercial bel air à rambouillet c'est
le 76e magasins de l'enseigné en france
est le troisième dont les yvelines et
1500 mètres carrés dédiés à la lecture
aux jeux vidéo à la musique et mais
aussi aux loisirs créatifs une nouvelle
offre culturelle qui permet également de
booster l'économie locale propos
recueillis par aurélie aurélie rose
nous sommes sur une base des vingt six
26 employés dont tu 25,1 des termes
d'embauché du bassin de rambouillet
c'est-à-dire sondés rambolitains ou bien
habite juste à côté de rambouillet est
bonne nous escomptons embaucher encore
quelques personnes
léman qui vient pour la fin d'année ou
bien si notre activité adeler sort nous
espérons augmenter nos effectifs nous
vous présentions le dispositif il ya
quelques mois sur tv 60,18 la boutique à
l'essai de magny les hameaux a depuis
ouvert à ses portes
une coiffeuse profite de cette opération
mise en place par le parc naturel
régional de la haute vallée de chevreuse
elle lui permet de bénéficier d'un
accompagnement à la création de
l'entreprise ou d'un le mot loyer
négocier cette boutique est une première
en ile-de-france et apporte aussi une
réponse à la problématique de la
disparition des commerces locaux en
centre ville écoutez sur ce sujet le
maire de la commune au micro de nicolas
kirillovitch l'e commerce et du service
de proximité pour les habitants
n'implique que les services publics et
plus on a de services de proximité pour
les habitants
mieux les habitants peuvent vivre dans
la commune look c'est un enjeu fort pour
une commune d'avoir ces commerces de
proximité et pouvoir les maintenir
surtout dans un environnement où on a
beaucoup de gros centres villes ou
grands centres commerciaux
ces commerces de proximité évite les
déplacements et sont vraiment des
services locaux directs pour pour nos
habitants pour bien vivre et cette
première boutique à l'esa ouvert ses
portes le 29 juin dernier un salon de
coiffure dans le quartier du buis sion
du buisson à magny les hameaux
comment se sont déroulées les premières
semaines d'activité le point avec
mathilde et demi vous vous souvenez
sûrement de cette pétillante coiffeuse
qui avait vu son projet de salon de
coiffure se réaliser grâce à ma boutique
à l'essai elle nous ouvre ses portes
quelques mois après son installation
j'ai bien travaillé je suis très très
contente ouais depuis le 29 juin bon il
ya eu les départs de vacances donc là ça
a super bien marché jusqu'au 15 juillet
ils vont petit à petit ça s'est étiolée
les gens partaient en vacances donc mais
bon tout le monde ne part pas donc non
je franchement j'ai très bien travaillé
une concrétisation pour cette coiffeuse
anciennement à domicile qui arrive
doucement à fidéliser sa clientèle une
installation nécessaire qu'elle
bénéficie grâce à son projet de salon
les premiers retours
j'ai déjà
des gens qui sont revenues au bout d'un
mois donc ça but est de les fidéliser
mais les gens sont contents parce que
sur le centre commercial ici il ya que
moi en tant que coiffeuse
autrement il faut aller au centre bourg
qui est un kilomètre 1 km 5
donc pour les gens qui n'ont sont pas
véhiculés c'est ça rend service et ya
toujours eu un salon de coiffure au but
sans cette nouvelle chef d'entreprise
cherche à présent à donner plusieurs
coups de ciseaux pour recevoir à
l'avenir encore plus de clientèle
mes objectifs et bah c'est effectivement
de d'embaucher quelqu'un qu'on voit ça 2
que ce soit sympa puis l'avenir l'avenir
le dira une ambiance que cette coiffeuse
veut amicale et sympathique pour que son
salon perdure dans le centre de manille
et hameaux nous vous avons parlé dans ce
journal de la rentrée des classes des
parlementaires en septembre les livres
aussi font leur rentrée
quels sont les ouvrages à ne pas rater
cette année sélection de pauline amiet
bonsoir vous êtes la directrice de la
librairie le pavé du canal à montigny le
bretonneux vous avez apporté avec vous
deux romans recommandé par votre
librairie alors le premier le titre
sebaï de rivers of babylon c'est écrit
par ken miller aux éditions zulma
peut-être un mot déjà sur l'auteur c'est
un auteur jamais car l auteur voyage
américain il est poète il a longtemps
vécu en jamaïque et maintenant il vit en
grande-bretagne
et là il dresse un portrait de la
jamaïque des années 80 et qui est assez
réaliste éclairé jamaïque en tout cas
d'aujourd'hui
ça n'a pas tellement évolué qu'est ce
qui vous a plus particulièrement dans
son roman alors déjà l'écriture sas
c'est assez propre aux îles francophones
comme haïti
où toutes les îles en tout cas très
attaché à l'écriture l'a jamais qu'en
fait partie on a peu d'auteurs
américains aujourd'hui
en tout cas c'est une écriture très
poétique très vivante et très vibrante
et ce qui est intéressant dans ce dans
ce livre c'est qu'on se fait une idée de
la jamaïque un peu comme une île de rêve
berceau du reggae etc et c'est au
contraire une île très violentes et
notamment violente à cause des
disparités à kingston sa capitale ont
été clos et bien là la réalité sur tf1
en fait ça se passe dans un quartier
pauvre de kingston qui s'appelle auguste
horn et qui est essentiellement habité
par des rastafari qui est une vraie
religion là bas qu'il ya une vraie
culture et des principes et des idéaux
et le développement de kingston à
l'international pour les touristes s'est
écrasé peu à peu cette communauté et on
suit le destin d'un petit garçon qui
revient de l'école et sa grand mère se
rend compte que l'enseignant art
opposition rastafarisme lui a coupé ses
dreads essai c'est vraiment faim ça
c'est une vraie attaque pour cette
religion et pour cette communauté
et elle elle va revenir sur toute
l'histoire de la communauté rastafari en
jamaïque et notamment augusto bail de
rivers of babylon de kayes miller c'est
aux éditions zulma alors le deuxième
ouvrage que vous avez amené sur un
plateau ces jeunes de regrets railroad
de coleson white ide et donc c'est édité
chez albin michel
alors pour situer l'histoire du roman on
est on est juste avant la guerre de
sécession aux mêmes siècle alors ça
c'est un gros gros coup de coeur de la
librairie et
ça fait l'unanimité au niveau national
et international il a reçu le prix pour
deux prix pulitzer et le national book
award le dernier qui a vu ces deux là
c'était les raisons de la colère
donc c'est plutôt de bon augure pour
colson whitehead
on va partir sur les chemins de london
ron wood qui est alors le l'auteur s'est
fait une petite image de ça on lui a
toujours parlé de ça est enfant il est
il est afro-américain et il a des
ancêtres qui étaient esclaves et on lui
parlait de ce chemin de fer qui pour lui
effectivement été sous terre ce qui
n'est pas le cas c'est un chemin de fer
à l'air libre mais part de ce principe
là et on suit le destin d'une jeune
esclave qui s'appelle cora dont la mère
a déjà réussi à s'évader dont elle n'a
plus de nouvelles et dans sa plantation
où elle subit les violences et les
attaques sexuelles du propriétaire elle
décide de s'enfuir avec un autre esclave
et ils vont essayer de gagner l'amérique
libre en tout cas anti esclavage ça va
pas du tout se passait comme ils veulent
seulement on a une vision assez binaire
de de cette période là mais c'était pas
anti esclaves et enfin un esclave
agissent mais et pro les mentalités
mettait du temps à changer et elle l
arrivée un peu trop tôt mais en tout cas
vous pouvez retrouver cet ouvrage à la
librairie le pavé du canal de
montigny-le-bretonneux je rappelle ce
titre underground railroad de coleson
wanted et c'est édité chez albin michel
merci pauline américaine avec nous et
directrice de la librairie le pavé du
canal à montigny le bretonneux et pour
connaître lé jour d'ouverture et tous
les horaires de la librairie rendez vous
sur le site internet du pavé du canal ce
week end ce sont les journées du
patrimoine thème cette année la jeunesse
saint quentin en yvelines a décidé de
développer ce thème à travers les
oeuvres sociales
un parcours en bus de ville près à lévis
en on va vous entraîner dans cette
histoire mélanie poquet et camille
lambert
que faire des enfants abandonnés des
jeunes délinquants
une préoccupation au 19e siècle lié à la
révolution industrielle
une paupérisation de la population le
musée de la ville tend à la faire
connaître à elancourt un orphelinat la
fondation méquignon une abbaye est un
lieu emblématique sa chapelle qui dit
abbaye dit forcément un lieu de culte
donc cette chapelle qui était qu'avec
pierre d'autel évidemment à la base on
était célébré des messes à laquelle
assistaient des orphelins de l'abbaye
et puis la baie en elle même était tenu
par départ des bonnes soeurs dirigé par
au départ par la soeur gabrielle qui est
cofondatrice avec l'abbé méquignon de ce
lieu donc cette chapelle elle était
vraiment centrale pour l'abbaye
c'était c'était le centre du domaine et
autour d'elle a été les établissements
d'accueil des enfants la belle méquignon
turé d'elancourt créer son orphelinat
dès 1859
la fondation est reconnue d'utilité
publique en 1866 donc là on va aller
voir le sait est donc centre de
formation aux métiers du bâtiment
de villepion donc ça c'est l'affectation
actuelle de l'école une idée de
formation déjà présente 130 ans plus tôt
l'école d'horticulture le nôtre est
fondée en 1882 sur le modèle des oeuvres
de georges bonjean un juge qu'ils
considéraient les enfants délinquants
comme des victimes
elle prendra le nom de fennec jardinier
de versailles en 1896 et elle
fonctionnera jusqu'en 1963 comme école
d'horticulture donc cette école elle
avait bien sûr des salles de classe
comme toutes les écoles mais surtout un
parc et dessert pour apprendre aux
enfants à jardiner et parlent à leur
apprendre les vertus de la terre il ya
tout aussi une idée de que la terre est
bénéfique par rapport à l'univers urbain
qui lui était vicié et vicieux où un
huissier un jardin à la française un
anglaise dessert il n'en reste
aujourd'hui que ce bassin les journées
du patrimoine la battre on le plaint
également du côté de chevreuse le
château vestiges du 11e siècle le
château de la madeleine pardon vous
accueille samedi et dimanche le
programme avec mathilde 2000
les journées du patrimoine approche et
le château de la madeleine dans le parc
naturel de la haute vallée de chevreuse
se prépare à accueillir ses visiteurs
on est au sein de la cour du château de
la madeleine où va se dérouler donc
durant tout le week-end des journées du
patrimoine une reconstitution de
campement médiéval donc un campement du
milieu du 15e siècle qui sera
mis en place dont part qui sera animé
par la compagnie à historia c'est une
reconstitution de campements qu'on fait
depuis depuis plusieurs années les
visiteurs apprécient apprécié énormément
cette cette animation
une reconstitution qui mérite une bonne
organisation pour recevoir les tendres
qui abriteront des ateliers et des
démonstrations de la vie au moyen-âge en
parallèle de feu de ce campement se
déroulera donc un atelier donc intitulé
patrimoine en poésie cette année le
ministère de la culture a décidé de
choisir comme thématique patrimoine et
jeunesse qui invite donc les enfants de
8 à 12 ans à écrire sur sur le
patrimoine de la région
des journées du patrimoine qui met à
contribution petits et grands pour
transmettre la culture historique des
lieux le temps d'un week end programme
riche vous l'avez vue pour ces journées
du patrimoine à tous à noter également
dans vos agendas
un classique tous les ans à la rentrée
les 16e rencontre de la cense se déroule
de vendredi à dimanche c'est au haras de
la cense à rochefort en yvelines avec
moi plateau pour en parler and de
sainte-marie bons soirs comme ça vous
êtes la directrice du haras de la cense
alors les rencontres de la cense ce sont
trois jours de programmation
exceptionnelle on va le voir dans un
instant c'est avant tout un événement
dédié à l'éthologie qu'est ce que c'est
concrètement l'éthologie alors
lithologies c'est la science du
comportement des animaux en général et
en particulier au haras de la cense des
chevaux donc c'est des connaissances sur
comment se comportent les chevaux au
naturel qu'on utilise pour les éduquer
en les respectant
et cette méthode d'éducation elle est
importée faut le dire il ya en 1999 le
fondateur du haras de la cense william
kriegel qui a donc ramené 7
ce mode d'éducation que les états unis
ça c'est si serré aux états unis on
appelle sa nature à leur semaine cheap
et c'est donc c'est se comporter avec
les chevaux en prenant en compte leur
comportement naturel et c'est vrai que
ça a eu un grand succès en france et
aujourd'hui c'est très généraliste mais
pour soir
voir d'ailleurs cette méthode
d'éducation l'éthologie dans le film
l'homme qui murmurait à l'oreille des
chevaux c'est tout elle fit un film de
robert redford alors le concept de ces
journées depuis deux ans il a changé un
peu un ces rencontres de la sens c'est
de mêler l'équitation
l'éthologie et aussi les sujets de
société c'est une nouveauté depuis trois
ans depuis deux ans tout à fait il ya
deux ans c'était la question autour du
bien-être du cheval qui est une question
générale sur le bien être des animaux la
place des animaux dans notre société
cette année on a choisi l'éducation donc
l'éducation au sens large donc dans la
société quelles sont les problématiques
et à l'équitation et à l'éducation par
le sport et en quoi le cheval peut
contribuer à y répondre et après plus
pratiquement comment on éduque des
chevaux et des cavaliers
il ya d'ailleurs pour traiter cette
thématique de l'éducation il y aura un
invité exceptionnel le samedi c'est luc
ferry qui est un ancien ministre de
landry et oui qui vient poser en fait
les questions que se posent de la
société et avec un parterre de
professionnels et de scientifiques se
demandent est en fait le cheval il est
entre la famille et l'école est bien en
quoi il peut avoir un rôle de médiateur
une présence le vendredi de luc ferry
l'ancien ministre de l'éducation donc
c'est pour cette première journée des
rencontres de l'ascension aura également
deux autres personnalités des comédiens
qu'on connaît très bien
c'est alex lutz et thierry lhermitte qui
viendront également pour ces rencontres
de la sens tout à fait ça c'est le
dimanche
en fait en témoignant de leur passion et
de leur parcours puisque l'un comme
l'autre ont découvert cette approche
écologique avec une vrai amour des
chevaux et viennent le partager avec le
public avec beaucoup de générosité et on
les en remercie alors chaque année je
crois les rencontres de la cense ça
regroupe 5000 participants là l'objectif
cette année c'est de faire encore plus
son image elle a toujours plus alors on
est on prie pour la météo qui est quand
même notre principal ennemi cette
semaine mais oui bien sûr toujours plus
de monde pour que pour partager avec le
plus de monde notre passion du cheval
l'idée c'est de partager cette passion
et c'est vrai qu'à écouter merci un de
sainte marie
directrice du haras de la cense ils
organisent je rappelle ce vendredi de
vendredi à dimanche
elle est 16ème rencontre de la sensée de
10 heures à 18 heures tarif de 16 euros
vin et on peut retrouver plus
d'informations d'ailleurs sur le site
internet du haras de la cense c'est
lassant ce point com
merci d'avoir été avec nous une info
pratique avant de refermer ce journal
saint quentin en yvelines à simplifier l
accès aux sept déchetteries du
territoire de nouvelles cartes d'accès
permettent depuis 1er septembre un accès
sur site 7 jours sur 7
à chaque profil sa carte pour identifier
le dépositaire les particuliers peuvent
se rendre aux déchetteries jusqu'à 50
fois par an si vous possédez déjà un
badge pas besoin de renouvellement
demandes de cartes et renseignements sur
le site sky point fr slash déchets c'est
la fin de ce journal merci de l'avoir
suivi à ré prix plaît et reportages à
retrouver sur notre site internet et
notre application mobile la tv
soixante dix huit bonne soirée à tous
[Musique]